Italy is not just protecting its culture
it's also protecting uh the way that it
eats check this out from Forbes Italy
will ban the sale of lab-grown meat and
other synthetic Foods choosing Heritage
natural over Laboratories fake anyone
who violates this will face fines up to
000 Lira again I thought this was
interesting not that the the meat versus
not meat okay is what it is but they're
saying hey we don't have to do this in
the name of climate we it we're Italian
we love good food Manja everybody right
like we don't have to go down this path
now they're banning it you might say
that that's a bit extreme Perhaps it is
but they're doing what they think is
right and of course the whole world in
the G7 and the globalists and everything
they're very angry at them because they
want them to cut back on meat and eat
bugs like the rest of you will be eating
bugs as you're in Mark Zuckerberg's uh
metaverse
[Music]
foreign